let's even your father that beam was Bob
he tried to cut of Jeju fiscal
responsibility when you're growing up I
believe well that's a generous way of
putting it my father is um I think with
the politically correct term is stingy
frugal it's actually funny you don't
make your mother kind of reprimanding
you in that way because my father it
felt something we were the adults at one
time I remember we were hot it was if we
were at flam bards the aerial theme park
yes and I was very young and I found a
camera under a bench you know like when
I was an icicle family camera took it to
my dad and I said dad I just found his
camera we should hand it in and he went
no he shouldn't you know you know the
law of the land
Finders Keepers losers weepers we used
that camera for five years this is
before digital so he couldn't download
what was on there this boy the poor
family just ripped that film out that
was gone we used that for five years and
then we went to however we went to a
holiday in Greece and I left it in a
restaurant and we went back and it was
gone and Mike the first thing my dad
said leaving bastards
just anything his mind is like he hadn't
grown up with much money and so sort of
where you could cut corners or fever
clearly the one time we we were young
again I'm sure he doesn't have a TV kind
of TV here the same Vicki um ever once
my my sister was very young and and it
was she was losing a lot of teeth and
getting you know putting them under the
pillow and getting money from the Tooth
Fairy and I won so she came down I
remember we were all there and she set
up dad why is it that when I put a tooth
under there I only get fifty P and all
my friends get a pain from the tooth
fairy and my dad quick as a flash just
looked at my mom and went because all
the other two fairies have wives that
work
[Applause]